[Music]
I think generally artists are much more
inclined to just embrace ambiguity than
the business world ambiguity lies in the
unknown so does art whereas business
lies in facts lies in specifics this
equals this and if you do this you'll
get that work and reward in in art you
have to find your own reward in it so
you still need it's still a work reward
system meritocracy but the rewards are
different I try to encourage young
actors or writers or directors to go
into the arts for the right reason and
that is the love of the art and if
actors and I can always tell when when
they're not heading in the right
direction is when they're looking at
something as some sort of stepping stone
to something else I'm like in Los
Angeles which is not a theatre town but
you will hear often actors say I'm going
to do a play so that I get an agent so
that I can get some work in television
so that I and it's like oh brother
if I can give you some advice
don't do the play if if the if your goal
is to achieve something else other than
the experience of telling this story in
this play you're setting yourself up to
fail
I try to discourage as much as encourage
young people from entering into the arts
because they are in for a lot of
tremendous frustration or they will just
simply give up when there is there is
resistance
what they perceive to be resistance I
knew I had this epiphany that I knew I
wanted to become an actor and that meant
for me I was all-in I'm not going to
have a fallback plan I'm not going to
give it some arbitrary two-year kind of
limitation and if I don't achieve X by
two years then I'm or what I hear this
all the time and it's like what does
that mean
achieve what if you're acting you should
do it because you you are empowered by
the function of acting of storytelling
writing directing even producing it's
all all related and you really have to
get it into it for the right reasons I
think I think artists of any kind
dance painting sculpture acting writing
musicians who are like jazz musicians
they live in ambiguity it's like I'm
gonna go here tonight don't know why
just felt like it trust your feelings
trust your instincts certainly for
actors if every night on stage is
exactly the same then you're not you're
not paying attention
you're not listening you're in because
it cannot possibly be the same
it could be familiar and similar but
there might be subtle or nuanced changes
from night to night different and that's
good it's good it keeps you alive it
keeps you awake and I think I think
we're we're just more comfortable in
ambiguity and I think by and large a lot
of stories that end ambiguously are more
satisfying because they're they feel
more real sometimes art should be kept
in the impressionistic realm that it's
it's not so neat and clear and oh this
person ended up with this person and
they lived happily ever
No maybe we feel at the end of a film or
a play this character that I've been
following I think now has a chance to
find happiness for this I'm good with
that they have a chance I hope they do
and that's good so I I think it's a it's
a great place to live and it it thrives
and it should be not only supported but
nurtured ambiguity in the arts
[Music]